[Music]
good afternoon my name is Sammy xuer
Dean I'm a staff solution architect on
the cloud platform team I'm gonna be
talking to you today about cloud
forensics cloud forensics machine
learning server this DevOps
quantum computing forensics edge no that
would be a great talk
that's that's like everything I could
throw in there no this talk is cloud
forensics 101 and I hope by the title
that sort of that clued folks in the 101
is sort of we're starting with the
fundamentals we're starting with the
basics and then from there we're
advancing we wouldn't be much we
wouldn't be a much shape talking about
advanced subjects if we weren't covering
the basics so that's definitely kind of
the level set we're going to talk about
techniques practices things you need to
do for your environment and hopefully
leave you with a lot of practical things
that you can do this is not necessarily
to talk about security we do a lot to
secure our environments and perfect
security is a goal perfect security
should be the outcome or the goal of any
security program but we live in a world
where infiltrations happen that's just
unfortunately the reality we hear about
them and when we hear about them they're
not great sometimes we don't hear about
them they're taking care of internally
but when we do hear about them they've
been in some cases you know it's not
uncommon to hear months or years that
that something has been allowed to sit
there some bad actor has been allowed to
act in our environment and they're up to
no good they're up to stealing from us
could be stealing sensitive customer
data it could be stealing our trade
secrets it could be stealing literally
you know half a penny at a time that
would make a great movie
but maybe it's not a half a penny maybe
it's half a coin in this case maybe it's
half a Bitcoin it's not an uncommon
application where they're literally
stealing your your computing resources
but regardless they're in our
infrastructure and if we turn it into an
engineering problem for a second our
goal is to optimize the time from which
they have possibly landed on our
infrastructure or our environment the
time we were able to detect in and get
rid of it
we want to optimize to minimize dwell
time if we want to get you know from the
time they they figure out how to create
an exploit to the time that we're able
to do something about that we want that
to be as little as little as possible
because the longer we we allow that to
fester that's money potentially lost so
what are the objectives for today what
also amazes me is that yes infiltrators
are making their way into our
infrastructure despite security measures
but it's also when these stories come
out about how things happen it's
fascinating to watch the process and
progression that professionals in that
space where they're looking at you know
how to uncover the bad guys the process
they go through and kind of one of the
fundamental pieces is that it's not
magic it's forensic they're looking at
they're looking at data much like any
other profession they're looking at
pieces of evidence that allow them to
formulate a certain pattern of behavior
and then uncover things so today's
activity really is largely focused
around that activity we're going to talk
about a number of things we need to be
doing in our environments to help that
process along we're going to go over the
tools explicitly this is kind of the
highest level level gets you in the talk
the rest of the talk will talk about
tools and configurations of tools and
things that we can do and also at the
end we'll sort of wrap up with a an
example of what of a whole forensics
pipeline looks like this is cloud and so
it wouldn't be complete without talking
about things we can do in an automated
fashion to really sort of make our make
our whole forensics activities with our
in our environments a little more
seamless all right so standard
disclaimer going through your
environments and looking for what a bad
actor may be doing and try to uncover it
and try to get it out of your
environment it's serious business it
shouldn't be taken lightly
there is a trade craft out there for
those who are design you know trained to
look at Incident Response to figure out
you know to find a bad guy within your
infrastructure and and it's our job to
help them it's our job to really put
together a very concise and very well
curated set of in
that allows those individuals if you're
here that's great but allows those
individuals to minimize the amount of
time that something bad isn't it's
inside of our environment to kind of
analogize this to to being medically
informed and making sort of like you
know the good choices when it comes to
sort of like you know your diet or your
exercise or things you know you can you
can get away with googling a bunch of
stuff to live really you know a good
life but at some point or another you
have to decide you know it's time to
call in a doctor it's time to sort of
step it up and that's the way I'd
encourage you to look at the information
we're going to present here it is pretty
handy and it does sort of open your eyes
to what's available but try not to be
over Kevin here and no one to bring in
the right resources all right so we're
gonna walk through these stages these
are sort of different stages of our
categories of activities that we want to
walk through in the process of helping
prepare our environment for dealing with
an incident if an incident happens we
want to be as well prepared as we can
it's going to suck it's not something we
want to go through but we can either be
extremely poorly prepared in which case
we just you know don't know where to
start we're literally starting at square
zero square one or we can be in a much
better position and that's our objective
here today is to be in a much better
position and generally we sort of move
to the right of this of this
orchestration of events but our
activities are going to fall in this
bucket and today just as sort of like
you know in full transparency today
we're really going to be talking about
collection this is really how we boost
our position and give an analyst or
somebody that's investigating an
incident the best ammunition to sort of
move forward
I said we're going to talk about
collection mainly but it wouldn't be
complete without talking about
prevention and and by that I mean this
is the these are the kinds of activities
that we go through in securing our
infrastructure and in a high level you
could think of it as the the three-step
sort of process is secure your perimeter
go through defense in depth and then
monitor how your how you're doing at any
given point but the reason this is
important this is sort of a symbiotic
talk I mean there's so many talks
regarding you know securing your
infrastructure in and how to properly
lock things down but insofar as when we
talk about it in today's context or in
the context of forensics the reason we
do this is on its own value it's a
critically you know needed with our
Innova environments but if we don't do
it we're going to generate a bunch of
noise a bunch of garbage and this is
sort of the adage of you know garbage in
garbage out if we've left everything
wide open to the internet and we're just
being bombarded with attacks we don't
want to float through a bunch of
needless information to our downstream
processes our downstream analysis we
need to take care of making sure things
like our software predatory if we are
building software and we're sourcing
components from different locations are
we keeping up with the security
bulletins are the vulnerability
bulletins with those libraries if we're
not then that's something obviously an
attacker is gonna find and and leverage
and say oh they're using unpatched
version X we can fight you know we can
use a well-known exploit so these are
activities that absolutely must be done
and if you don't do it then it's it's
not only to sort of weakening your
environment it's gonna make it so that
we're ending up gonna end up calling
wolf or crying wolf or a bunch of times
and making it really difficult for a
professional to come in and properly
analyze the environment and by the way I
mean not only is it time time is money
in terms of like how quickly we uncover
where a bad actor is planted something
in our environment these resources
generally they're doing the analysis
they cost money you want them to come in
and you want them to sort of not have to
wasted a lot of time on finding the
right you know finding the needle in the
haystack
so the great English man once said who
here likes audience participation let's
organize into groups of 20 it no it's
not organizing Crips 20 let's call it
out what are what are some things that
sort of clue out cause one to think that
they've been that they have an incident
going on or somebody's found a way into
their infrastructure go ahead
respite resource usage maybe the good
anomalous network traffic serverless
yeah go ahead
blackmail ransom notes so there's a lot
of things that go on point is all those
people are probably in the craft in and
the point is everybody should have an
incident response plan if you don't you
know look around it sounds like there's
about 400 of us here that might be able
to help out but we should have an
incident response plan to to know what
to do it could be literally a law you
know some authority or some law
enforcement that's come in says here
reason to believe that you're sending a
lot of data to places you shouldn't be
sending data so whatever it is think
about yourself in that moment and what
are you going to do if somebody says you
know there is strong evidence here that
you're going to be compromised so this
isn't that list of to dues I'm gonna
give you a couple not to do this okay
first one is do not simply say oh my
gosh I'm panicked I don't know what to
do
somebody's in my infrastructure I know
what to do this is cloud I'll hit delete
we don't want to do this for a couple of
reasons number one is it just it just
completely obliterates the forensic
trail that you want to follow but in the
chess match of if you think about it
that way if you think about somebody
trying to figure out how to take
advantage of your infrastructure
you've made a very naive move you've
told your opponent that you really maybe
don't have a game plan you haven't
figured things out and if they were
unaggressive at that point they're gonna
get highly aggressive after they see
that you're on to them maybe they're
going to step up exfiltrating all your
data maybe they're gonna step up their
attack maybe they're gonna lock you out
of their infrastructure so you will
obviously terminate your infrastructure
but do it at the right time don't make a
naive move that accelerates things
needlessly the key point is take a small
breath
say I have a plan I know what to do I'm
not gonna give away my hand and reveal
to an attacker that I know they're in my
infrastructure don't be a hero do not
grab don't be you know oh we're
infiltrated I know what to do I got this
I'll just log into the server using SSH
so it's secure realize what no there's a
machine that's been compromised I mean
somebody has figured out how to take
advantage of it and so in some form or
another if you log into a machine that's
knowingly compromised you are in some
way handing over credentials to an
attacker so don't have the inclination
to do that now these two things are very
important because I'm not rest of this
talk is gonna be largely centered around
so what do I do you know how do I get
around these things I do want to know
what's going on in these environments
but but generally speaking don't don't
don't log in and sort of say I you know
I I know think of the two about top and
graben and PS and I can look at logs
it's not it's not our general plan so
the bulk of today bulk of today is
collecting things like we said resources
and the professionals that are going to
come in to do this work for you you
could either say I have no idea what's
in my environment please take a look
here are my credentials go ahead and
they're gonna start from square one not
only does that cost you time and money
it's just not an efficient use of time
we're trying to get folks out of our
infrastructure so we want to go through
collection we want as part of our
preparation process things we're going
to have done ahead of time is to be
collecting a lot of information so that
when something happens we're gonna say
here is you know yes you're finding a
needle in a haystack but we've really
curated the haystack down to make it a
very small bundle of things we think
there's something in here we think what
you're gonna find is in here please take
a look and it's generally these three
buckets logs
disks and live information live
information because more and more were
we're not in a situation where we're
dealing with infected or compromised
hosts that are that are sitting under
our desks are sitting inside of our
office
we're in cloud so in cloud you don't
have that liberty right you have to
think about how to do things over the
wire
the internet and so more and more we
need tools and mechanisms to connect to
things while they're online while
they're on the network so generally
we're going to go through activities for
the rest of this talk that are talking
about how to collect logs what to do
about getting disks this are obviously
one of the most essential pieces of
information and in an analyst job and
then how to collect information
real-time live over the network before
we collect anything though we want to
put things into a secured location we
don't want to collect all these you know
buckets of information and then have
that bucket be a leaky bucket we want to
basically put them into a vault and that
vault if you think about the Google
project organization you're gonna have
projects your projects are where your
services are running things that are
talking to the internet and this is
where your quote/unquote compromised
activity might be happening but on the
other side of that your security
apparatus within your organization
you're those who are responsible for
collecting these artifacts they should
have their own highly isolated
environment a separate project and
that's designated for art attacks it's
it's for artifacts it's a one-way flow
of information and we're gonna set it up
so that the only folks that have access
to that is a highly highly sort of
refined list of individuals this isn't
something that even that most faithful
should know exists but set this up first
so that we can we have a destination for
everything so logs was the first thing
in our agenda logs is a broad category
anybody that's how to troubleshoot a
problem knows that logs is your your
best asset and within cloud platform
there's sort of two camps of logs
there's logs that we generate as part of
Google that tell you everything about
your environment and these are admin
activity logs so who launched an
instance who modified a firewall rule
and data access so if you're using any
of our data products like bigquery and
you're storing all your customer data in
bigquery well that's that becomes a
tangible asset that's a vector for
somebody to try to come in and an attack
so we can log
activities regarding your data access so
we take care of that these are platform
generated logs the other side of the
fence is logs that you generate logs
that your application generates and so
we're going to talk about basically each
one of these individually and we're
where you should wear you should
destined these things so the nice thing
is that within cloud platform there is a
facility called stackdriver logging this
is how we surface all log information to
you but it's not simply for the platform
generated logs it's a full-fledged
logging service and this is where you
would instrument and say hey I'm gonna
be generating logs from my instances I'm
gonna be generating logs from my
application those are all going to
basically end up in the same monolithic
point now if you have another logging
instrument that's fine but the point is
you should be sending all logs to some
centralized place that allows you to
pivot and look at it now the platform
generator logs like I said those are
just given to you automatically those
they make their way into stackdriver
logging but you have to do a couple
things in order to get user logs and
application logs into into that
environment so we'll talk about it as
three phases and just filtering and
export so ingest is really simple it's
actually a very friction on this thing
when you're creating your VMs or when
you're creating your environment make
sure to install a stack driver logging
agent it's the logging agent that's
essentially a packaged flew in the agent
and that's really all you have to do
it's pre-configured to look at all the
standard normal places within your
operating system your syslog and other
activities and as soon as it turns on
its going to be able to use the instance
information authenticate and send it to
this director of or logging API you can
do this from AWS as well and set and
install the logging agent on your ec2
instances and it'll go effectively to
one destination in your application code
we have support for several different
languages essentially in your
application code instead of one approach
that may be just to be logging out to
the system level logging the other is
your application code directly could
instrument talking this doctor over API
and so if you got the sort of async
process which is just sending out log
information if you're running in server
so you're running in an environment
where you can't necessarily
on collecting the system-level logs you
want to omit those logs directly from
your application then you would simply
turn around with a lot of samples on how
to include logging capabilities within
your application code directly and those
doesn't necessarily need to go through
through the operating system once it's
in stackdriver logging sector logging
I'm not making sort of any claims about
sort of the volume of logs and the cost
of logs and things like that that's
obviously something you should estimate
and figure out how long data should sit
there and in word should move and how
much it would cost but the nice thing is
once it's in stackdriver logging by and
large you get this sort of freeform
search you can do advanced filters you
can do custom filters you can look at
different things like if you wanted to
know why particular server is out of
sync you could run simply look for the
what the NTP daemon was doing was doing
on a particular instance are all
instances at a certain time and this is
gonna be really an instrumental later in
the talk where we show you can do some
fancy things with filtering that that
will tell you hey there's something
there's something fishy going on but
most likely this is sort of a pit-stop
stackdriver logging is a pit stop on the
way to something different we want to
save these logs like I said these the
order of magnitude on these attacks is
it's it's it's not a couple days or a
week sometimes we're finding out they're
months or years and so we want a
destination to send these logs to long
term stackdriver logging gives you three
outlets to send your information out to
bigquery which is kind of like the
choice I would sort of default here that
logs are already structured that lends
very nicely to export them to bigquery
where they'll already be searchable and
they're already be able to to query
against but then if you ever wanted them
out of bigquery in say a flat file
format you can always do an unload
operation out of bigquery you could just
send them flat out to cloud storage or
you could send them to pub sub those
Sookie's cases are interesting because
those of us who are operating another
type of logging infrastructure whether
you're operating
Splunk or something like that or you
have a sim your sock is leveraging a sim
and you want to basically say no I want
I have several different environments I
want everything to go into that sim this
is where you would pivot that
information you would say okay drop
into a bucket and I'll set up a bucket
trigger and I'll know to basically pull
that information in and the case of
Splunk and others if you send it to
pub/sub they're able to hook into that
pub/sub feed and bring things over but
the point is the objective is to move it
out what does that look like from a
technical perspective we do something
called setting up sinks and the sink is
decisively says hey stackdriver I know
the data is inside of inside of the
stack driver platform I want it out and
so you can in in a very terse amount of
language you can say what is the log
that I'm interesting in essentially set
up the filter and where do I want it to
go what stock driver will do is will
turn around and say okay I've gone ahead
and create that for you here's a
specific service account within your
environment that's going to be used for
this sink and go ahead and if you've
asked for it in this case to go to
bigquery notice these are not
necessarily in the same project because
we have our forensics project whatever
security project where all this data is
going and so it's important to turn
around and go to the data set or the
bucket or wherever your destiny this
information and say oh I need to take
that stack divert that service account
that stock driver told me is going to
use I needed grant at the appropriate
permission to be able to write to that
so this is great if you do this you've
got this kind of automated every
instance comes up you make it part of
the bootstrap process that every
instance is going to be able to send
this information off but this says tells
a syslog information syslog information
is great in terms of standard system
activities it's not perfectly useful
from if you want to go much deeper if
you want to go at the forensic level we
need to look at okay what is this
instance doing what is what are the
system calls that are being made who's
asking for different things to happen
so we need to go and upgrade the amount
of information we're getting from an
instance
so within Linux there's something called
the Linux auditing system which is
something you can tap into every single
activity there's something like 300 odd
sis calls that are being done within the
next but you can you can look at every
single activity you can look at every
time somebody touched a certain file
read a certain file you can look at when
somebody is asked to open a socket or or
listen on a socket so this is when
someone somebody is asked to run
something with privilege in
formation this information is actually
there and being emitted from the kernel
all the time there's a mechanism where
the kernel sends it over to the user
space for some tool to do what with it
it's not the kernel doesn't really
dictate that its uses something called a
net leak socket and says I'm just going
to dump this as a flood of information
out on this and so you can have things
that listen for that and pull it off
audit D is one such tool another such
tool would be OS query the tool is
really sort of your preference in your
choice but the point is you need
something in user land to basically
subscribe to that and take that off and
then send it in this case to logging so
we need to instrument that a couple
different ways which also in a second
but in this case every time somebody has
done something privileged in this case
somebody has done something using sudo
and we're interested in that it goes to
stackdriver logging because we've free
filled out our the collection part of
this with an agent then essentially we
just need to say yep this is one more
thing I want to learn without this kind
of information it's very very hard to
really get a picture of what the
instance was doing what the VM was doing
you'll sort of maybe see some startup
times some application launch times
without actually looking at kernel level
activities or audit level activities you
may not necessarily know like who did
what and what sense getting this on to
an instances is is is pretty
straightforward pretty trivial if you
think about previous slides we showed
hey you would have a startup script
install this factor of or logging agent
great pretty much with one command you'd
get all this back over logging it's
about the same here you well as I guess
is a few more than one command it's like
a long command so there's a couple
different things here one is we are
already sort of acknowledged that we're
gonna have a stack of our logging agent
ready to go but we're going to pull down
oddity and we need to do a couple things
one is we need to in that top little
block in the audit rules that's where we
tell audit d what am i interested in so
this is a this is this is about the
version that would fit on a slide it's
not necessarily to be meant to be
prescriptive you'd want to do some
research on oddity and see what kind of
calls are meaningful to be able to look
at in this case we're saying tell me
everything that has an effect of a UID
of zero like basically
anything like on the previous slide that
was being executed with sudo or as root
the other thing we need to do the back
half of that is great we're generating
on this formation it's going into audit
log stock driver by default doesn't know
that this is a source of logging that
we'd like to also include with the logs
that come off of this box so that end
piece there that says is a configuration
that says hey stock driver go ahead and
pay attention to this new log format
that I've dropped out and by the way
it's a little bit special it uses some
key value pairs it's it's it has to be
parsed a certain way in order to make it
in so that's that's roughly that's what
that format key value is but if you do
this great you got everything that's
happening from a syslog perspective
you've got everything down to everything
that the kernel is is thinking about so
in terms of logging positions we've got
our platform logs we've got our data
access logs we've got our application
server our os logs our application
server logs
I've got everything that's happening on
the instance now we know what's going
down to the kernel last kind of piece of
this is from a logging perspective is
flow logs flow logs essentially tell you
I've just finished describing everything
that's going on inside of an instance
everything is going on from a platform
perspective around an instance this is
sort of rounds out the piece so tell me
everything that's happening from a
network perspective everything that's
from a network traffic passing I think
somebody mentioned you know looking for
spurious Network patterns everything
that's being thrown back and forth
across our instances and it's not on by
default this is pretty chatty it's a lot
of data it's a lot of traffic but it's
something that you would want to look at
turning on so you'd go in your subnet
and you'd basically say turn flow logs
on and it's going to score it every TCP
and UDP flow some caveats it if it's a
single packet type thing it's based on
sampling so in some sampling senses it
may it may not pick up on very very low
packet and like single packet count type
things but if you've got something
that's studying a stream out which is
what a lot of attacks do this would be a
good way to pick up on it and because
it's in stock driver logging I can
formulate this search pattern now here
obviously everybody recognize this is
this is a great
DNS server to be using this is Google's
DNS server so this isn't necessarily
suspicious what would be suspicious
though is in your environment if you're
like why do I have any outbound DNS
traffic I have centralized DNS within my
environment instances kind of look
inward why am i sending DNS traffic out
to the to the to the Internet and there
are some exploits that are actually
pretty well known now that that take
advantage of exactly that using DNS
tunneling or DNS cat they're able to
sort of compromise a machine and say
make it look like a DNS query but every
time you make the query just piggyback
on this little little tidbit of
information and over time that
information gets accumulated on the
other side so this may be a very
interesting query not necessarily going
to Google but going out to somewhere
that you didn't expect all right
that is the entirety of logging what the
platform is doing what your data is
doing what the instance is doing very
deep and what's happening around it so
that kind of rounds out our picture of
logging collecting that information
putting in that logging basket and
having it be searchable because you've
sent it to a searchable endpoint you've
sent it to something not only inst a
crabber logging that you can query with
some advanced queries you've sent it to
bigquery now you're able to say you know
what I think I need to Zone in on
everything that was running on a
particular managed instance group or
anything with this particular tag or
anything with service a you've got a
point to basically come in and say great
I'm gonna carve out that set of logs and
the traffic patterns and the kernel
activities and send that somewhere we'll
talk about where to send it in a second
disks so this is usually that canonical
forensic hey I'm gonna do an
investigation activity to grab the disks
and send it to somebody that may or may
not look at them so we grab the disks
and look at it so obviously in a cloud
environment we don't have the disk grab
API yet you know where you can tell a
human being to grab it but that's not
what you want really what you want is
the disk and if you remember the
doughnuts the things not to do is do
this in an obtrusive way we don't want
to do this in a way that reveals that
we're doing something investigatory logs
happen say in the all those agents as
long as you make those part of your your
build up your boots
process all that information is spewing
and nobody is really the wiser from an
attacker perspective of how much
information is being sent off I mean
they they probably perceivably look but
you're not doing you're not
instrumenting something after they're
attacked it's just part of the normal
process this are the same way we don't
want to terminate discs and say oh no
but it's okay I just said to save the
discs we want a much more salient way to
instrument this we want to use cloud EAP
is to do this a little bit better what
this process would look like or does
look like is to enumerate the instance
or instances that you are interested in
okay
service a is compromised our micro
service B is compromised what are all
the instances that are running that come
up with a list of disks attached to
those instances and behind the scenes
they use a platform to make a copy and
those copies exist in logical form from
a from an object perspective within your
cloud account what we want is the
tangible artifact that can be sent to a
downstream tool so what does that look
like it's actually just three commands
it is possible to take a running disk
that's attached and make a snapshot from
it the reason we make a snapshot is
because these disks are attached if you
wanted to make it's a prerequisite for
the next step which is to create a disk
image from a source so you can create a
disk image from another from a from a
from a disk persistent disk but if that
persistent disk is attached we can't do
it so first we take a snapshot we create
a point in time of a disk that's
attached we create an image disk image
from that snapshot and then we can
export that disk image now this may be
something interesting just you know from
your own operational perspective how do
I get information that's running how do
I get a disk image that's running on
production and have a backup copy in
case you know I needed to change
environments or do something interesting
but this is incredibly effective because
we can create an entire external archive
in the form of a file that can be pulled
into another tool for analysis again an
attacker that's running something on an
instance you're running has no idea that
this activity took place okay that was
it for disks it's really really
straightforward and simple it's one of
the biggest things that you'll do in
your analysis
activity but I'd like to move on to the
last part of the puzzle which is last
part of the things we collect which is
live information again we need to talk
to environments that are up and so we're
sort of done with the things that the
platform and some agents and
bootstrapping can do we're gonna move on
to like how do I look at something that
is going on in the box you've been
informed as a compromise you know
there's an instance that's compromised
I want to login I can't login because I
would give my credentials away but
clearly there's something running in
memory on that box that's sending data
out so ger is an agent-based system it
actually installs in Windows Mac OS
Linux it's an open source project that
started at Google a while ago it's
actually since we're Google rapid arm
not cool sorry
ger Rapid Response to be cool you Sager
it's talking about the photo some of the
folks I contributed and create to it and
I kept saying grr and they saw that I
wasn't cool enough to give the talk
because I don't say girl so Sager to be
cool ger know before you go with great
power comes no that's wrong so it's a
lot of extensive capability it can let
you do literally anything and so it is
that sharp end of the spear that upon
which you can do pretty much anything
inside your environment so it's probably
a good idea to fortify the heck out of
it effectively it is the point at which
you could be rude on anything and look
at anything so there's an entire in the
in the ger read the docs there's an
entire section on how to secure it your
you know how do you front-end it how do
you put the right certificates on that
would be an entire talk on its own this
is just my way to make sure that Google
security people don't yell at me so but
secure it before you you move on ok once
you've got gir up and running there are
two main activities agents or clients
will report into it but there's two sort
of main things you would ask her to do a
flow or a hunt and so these are flow is
just an atomic unit of work you're like
hey that box right there
I'd like to look at it
file that box right there I'd like to
look at the memory that's running on
that particular process so ger can
essentially start a flow and say great
who do you want to target what do you
want to do on that machine and then that
machine would pull in and ask for if
there's any work a hunt would be sort of
under this new banner of threat hunting
if you just sort of go from a premise of
that you're always compromised there's
something always going on in your
environment then you may say you know
that I know that there's the shape of
this jar that's pretty bad or I know
there's this string that's pretty
indicative of a compromising I want to
be hunting my feet for any time that
shows up so so that's an example of a
ger flow I've asked for a process memory
dump so let's say for an example you
have a machine
somebody somebody is on attackers on
that machine and says you know
rudimentary I'm just gonna basically
take this file I'm gonna dump the entire
you know credit cards if no don't ever
do this I'm gonna take that and
basically make it look like some system
level file because I've made it look
like a swap file and I'm going to just
send it over a socket I've only got 20
minutes on this box and so you could
send this over and so now you've got
this process which is online which is
active which is egressing information
you're like hey that doesn't look right
so you start a flow and say I would like
I would like to dump that process so
girl will turn around and then when that
box makes contact and I'll say hey turn
around and run this flow and so you'll
see and the ger console it's like okay
cool
I'm bought this piece of work here
you've asked me to do and it'll go and
collect and then a few months later
you'll see that Haggar will say hey I'm
done I'm done collecting this memory
I've stored it in these however many
little artifact files these files you're
ready to come check it out sort of like
your dry cleaning is ready to pick up
and so you can pull those files down and
they're binary you know their files that
represent the binary representation of
what's in memory so you could do
something as simple as run strings on it
which would take that binary information
and turn it back into text and you could
see that essentially what I had sent was
sitting whatever you had been sending
was sitting resident in memory for that
process still hadn't been hadn't been
collecting garbage collected yet and you
would be able to dump that out and so
it's pretty powerful to be able to say
look I can actually look and reach
inside of a box and look at the memory
that's going
side of it it's not necessarily going to
be this easy this is is trivialized but
the point I'm trying to make here is
without girl you couldn't do this
remember your ham strong your hands are
tied behind your back because you can't
login you don't want to login you know
that's just a bad practice but with Gura
at least you can effectively do
everything you could you would need to
do had you been logged in guru actually
is designed to go on to agents like
Windows machines Mac machine you know
Mac OS machines machines that are out on
the Internet the agents are available
and be contacted from say a fleet of
instances or a fleet of workstations
that you're managing but in a cloud
deployment here for using in this sort
of centralized context where you're
having machines instances spin up in
different projects and contact in we'd
want to make it work in this sort of
again segmented approach where not
everybody has access to the ger server
it is a pull model so the nice thing is
that's not Gura reaching out and making
contacts and you having a deal with
firewalls in every single instance
agents on client install machines poll
periodically for activity and the nice
thing is then if they're offline they're
offline but when they come online they
can they'll say hey do you have any work
for me and the other thing gur does is
it has customized install binaries and
so you'll put those binaries in a
specific bucket and you'll set up your
internal firewall rules but the way to
do this sort of cross project because
again we want our security artifacts and
infrastructure in a different project
than our production ones we'd want to
set up VPC peering here this isn't
really that much of an incident of an
interesting slide but essentially that's
it's a few steps you can set up peering
between two pieces of infrastructure and
the main thing there is to make sure you
allow the relevant protocols into your
core server the ger server itself is
pretty easy to set up it's got Debian
packages it comes with docker I mean it
comes you can download a docker image
and run a docker image part of the setup
will interrogate you and ask you what is
the name by which clients are going to
contact me and you configure all that
information in what is the admin
interface going to be on you can figure
all that information in as part of the
setup and an after as it's doing the
setup it'll build custom install
binaries so it isn't something and this
is really salient because then these
custom these install binaries are just
ready to go so you put those into a
that's basically where they sit on the
management console and what you want to
do then is any piece of infrastructure
in your environment any compute that
needs to grab those binaries just make
sure you give those access to the bucket
and that's it it's a one it's a sort of
a one pulled you know pull down the
archive from from a bucket using gsutil
and then install it so now we've kind of
talked about three things in our install
script extractor our logging agent
oddity and the augur agent with this
we've got our logging information we've
talked about this collection and we've
talked about getting information using
live information so let's move on to
detection this is kind of where it
starts to get real we were in a good
position here we're in a position that
if somebody said tell me everything that
goes on your environment and you instead
of looking at them like a deer in the
headlights which is easy to do up here
with lights in your face instead of that
you can go I got this I can pull the
disc for you I can tell you what's going
on in memory I can pull logs related to
that incident I can bundle this all
together and hand it over
and so in detecting this this is where
you would employ any number of sort of
services maybe you're hunting for
malware maybe you're noticing that your
instances are beaconing out to some you
know trying to make contact with the
command and control server your IDs
probe picks it up unexpected processes
was called out earlier on an
unauthorized hiss calls why is something
and why is something trying to listen on
a port so let's say you put that all
together this is an example of what a
pipeline on cloud could look like a
forensics pipeline if you remember in
the beginning I said we'd sort of pull
all this together to make it look
interesting but imagine you have an
instance that's beaconing it's sending
out to some bad known IP so before the
fact you've sort of sourced a list of
bad IPs we'll talk about that in a
second and so you've got the Machine
beaconing which you're able to find out
because that's going in flow logs and
you've got a list of bad IPS that you've
configured as a filter because you're
like hey I can configure a filter to
look for certain IPS and if you saw if
you notice that you could tell some
worker process that says you know this
doesn't look right I want you to trigger
off of that and I want you to go and
collect everything you know about that
instance and because flow logs are
fairly chatty and that would keep
repeating you'd probably checkpoint
these results somewhere
say oh this is instance demo one it's
been compromised you don't want to kick
off this flow every time so you'd maybe
collect that information in fire store
and fire store house a few different
ways to use it
the way we're talking about here is
closed you don't want fire store open to
mobile and web you know this is this
this is just basically a holding around
for it's not a social app so there's the
holding ground to checkpoint your
results and so I'd turn around I would
do that I would say collect me the
memory grab the disks run this query to
collect all the logs for that instance
and send those to the next stage the
next stage would be I've got the memory
what do you want me to do kick off
another process which turns around and
analyzes that with volatility or recall
or something and I've got all these
time-based artifacts I've got disks I've
got logs I want to put those together in
a way I can look at them you create
what's called a super timeline which is
using some tools called plazo and time
sketch and oh by the way as this
activity was running one feature of
stack driver logging is that you can use
alerting and alerting can then not only
alert based on some metric it can do
notifications with pager duty and other
things and so your Incident Response
Team get some there it comes in and says
hey this bucket has a bunch of artifacts
or these VMs have a bunch of artifacts
that have been loaded up in their
analysis tools they need your eyeballs
on them right away so this is not
fictitious actually you can build this
with everything we've already talked
about and a lot of the things we've
already shown but I'll kind of just how
Lou to the things we haven't quite
talked about so Mis biz and
organizations ANZ's organizations these
are well-known organizations that help
collate and curate bad actor information
malware information and so they do have
the ability to sort of bring down a list
it could be earlier like we talked about
with DNS where it's maybe a particular
port that you know is troublesome but in
this case you could say well I just want
to down the top bad actor list and
because we're able to set up sinks
programmatically
like we set up earlier a sink for
archive this is a sink that's different
you notice a destination is actually
pub/sub and we've set up a topic here
called hey beaconing I think that if I
see somebody talking these bad IPs it's
pretty good indication that they're
beaconing out to make contact with
someone and so I could build this list
and sort of refresh this on a basis and
if it triggers boom I'm going to send it
to another I'm going to send it to a pub
sub topic and that will kick off the
activities that you saw on that worker
chain
so this payload comes in and that worker
says what you want me to do well it
turns out ger has an API and so if this
was the worker that's I'm gonna
illustrate the Gir activity it would say
cool what's in the payload of this
message that I just got in pub/sub and
the two things that are interesting
there are the source IP and the
destination IP so the first thing I
would do is I would contact the grapey I
and I would say give me the client give
me the client that has this IP and so
ger would search his database and say
here's a client or here's a list of
clients and then the next thing which is
more interesting I would say go do a net
stat on that machine go do a net stat
and tell me in that net stat who's
talking to this bad IP what process
give me the pit of the process talking
to this bad IP and then to come back and
say well here's the pit of who's talking
that IP based on the net stat great go
dump me in the memory for that pit I
want to know everything that's happening
in the memory on that pit that's talking
that bad IP because it shouldn't be this
is all done just basically talking and
interacting with the Gir api and it
started off with a trigger that was
based on some information that we can
easily source the next thing in our
pipeline after memory was building a
timeline the timeline essentially just
says when you can take a bunch of data
and extract the metadata that has to do
with time on that timeline and lay it
all out then it's you know you lay it
all out so that it sits chronologically
and you know able to be analyzed and
then layer on anything else that has
that time element because we're sort of
hunting and finding a cataclysmic event
and looking sort of around that and
around that to say oh that's where that
file was dropped and that's where that
process was launched that file was
dropped on the disk based on this
information and that process was
launched based on this user at this time
we want all that information so we take
all our logs anything that's
time-sensitive in our disks we send them
to log to Timeline it creates a super
timeline applause oh file falsify I
would just be a file would be sort of
hard to look at and sort of like a
spreadsheet fashion so we want a way to
sort of bring that together and
collaborate so there's another tool
called time sketch time sketch was
written by a Google engineer named
Johann Bergeron I hope I'm saying that
right and it sort of has this it's a
elastic search back but it has this
ability to load in all this timeline
information into sketches and say hey I
want to bring in time
what this does is it's a it's a focal
point for all your analysts to sort of
look at and say there's interesting
traffic right there I want to annotate
that I want to come back to that in my
workflow I want to look at how that
event connects to other events and so
you can do sort of all that
collaborative exercise with time sketch
and you can have multiple of these going
on if you have different events going on
at different times so how do I bring
things into passo on time schedule I'd
set up plazo I'd set up time sketch I'd
copy down the disk image after acquiring
a disk image I'd run log to Timeline and
create a timeline I basically do a bunch
of stuff and so would it be great is if
I didn't have to do all this stuff right
if it just somehow this could all be
sequenced together where I could
interact with the cloud EP eyes and
interact with all these forensic
analysis tools and sort of pull it
together and so I want to highlight a
couple tools in closing here is turbine
Ian's time wolf these are open source
projects they are used by certain teams
here at Google as well but they are
available and Soter binya is if you
recall like hey this activity I want to
create a oh I want to create a time
sketch I want to create a flow so I want
to runs I have this memory in these
files I want to run strings on it so
when you have forensic artifacts you
want to run an activity against those
friends of artifacts this is where you
would orchestrate that what robinia but
you also noticed in this whole pipeline
that whole long sequence of things I was
sequencing between different api's in
this process of building my forensic
pipeline and that's where a tool like DF
time will time wolf comes in or it can
say it's the plumbing or the glue that
kind of pulls together this ferret
actions between these two API is in the
goal of being able to kick off this
these more finer activities say inter
vineya so those are two tools you can
look at that lean very heavily into
cloud ap is a question might be hey
you've talked about all the things in VM
world how does this pertain to new
computing environments that containers
and serverless and a lot of the things
are applicable and the server list camp
actually very little is applicable
because you don't have control over the
execution environment you don't get the
logs from that environment but we do get
a standard out you know that's generally
what a service environment will pull
for you is that it'll it'll it'll send
to you whatever your environment was
sending standard out but in containers
there's some things we need to keep on
top of there's if we're looking at the
Cisco activity there's some utilities
like cystic or you can use the visor
there's a talk tomorrow here in this
room I think at 10:20 on G visor which
is how do I look at the what at a
container is doing and G visor kind of
goes a step beyond it not only looks at
what a container can do in terms of
syscalls but it can sandbox those so
you'd sort of have a white list of like
what should this container be able to do
so because it's sandboxing and
intercepting those his calls it actually
can log off of those so if that sounds
interesting attend that talk tomorrow G
visor is open sourced by Google recently
and it's super interesting and there's a
couple different ways to run on
container engine one is using container
optimizing us and then the other is a
boon to and so if you want to sort of
install any of these things or work with
the base operating system that generally
means you're gonna pick Lubuntu and then
the VMS are basically everything we
talked about but it's probably helpful
to sort of look at this compare and
contrast aspect okay so bottom line is
sort of a leave behind is that don't
don't go into panic mode
when something happens when you've been
alerted to something going on have a
plan and say the data you know the the
analysis is going to show that this
information be found out by looking at
certain data and that data is going to
be your logs your disks and your live
information and have that ready to
curate and pull together so when
something happens follow the plan gather
data use the tools mention to
collaborate it'll take many folks
working together to sort of pull all the
information together and find that
needle in a haystack and then again be
sure you bring in folks that know what
they're doing or have been trained to
low know what to look for so if the
patterns in this talk seemed interesting
to you and they're some of the things
that you look to employee will be
probably publishing these in the form of
a solution I work on solutions that I
published out to the community and I'll
probably try to publish these out but if
you want to get in touch before then and
sort of talk about these patterns please
reach out at next 18's forensics at
google calm
thank you and hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference
[Applause]
you
[Music]